now we can use the unique path
characterization of trees to very
quickly figure out that every tree is
too colorable so we know that a tree is
a graph with unique paths between every
pair of vertices and as a consequence
the chromatic number of a tree with two
or more vertices is 2 the proof is just
to show you how to color it you're
killing clearly can't get by with one
color if you've got any two adjacent
vertices the two colorable way is that
you just choose an arbitrary vertex and
call it the root but you make the
arbitrary choice on what the route is
and there's a unique path from every
vertex from the root to every vertex
using this unique path characterization
and so we're just going to color
vertices by whether the path from the
root is of autor even length if it's an
even length color it red and if it's odd
length color it blue a colored green and
so we wind up alternating red and green
and the fact is that adjacent nodes are
going to be at a distance where 1 is an
odd distance and one as an even distance
which is why this method of coloring is
going to work a general property of two
coloring is that to figure out whether
or not a graph is through colorable and
how to do it is you just start picking
arbitrary vertex give it a color it red
and then color all the vertices adjacent
to it green and keep going in that way
coloring a vertex with a color different
from an adjacent vertex that's colored
until you get stuck if you don't get
stuck it's 2 colorable and if it's not 2
a colorable you're guaranteed to get
stuck so it's a very easy way to figure
out if a graph is 2 colorable another
characterization that of two color
ability in general is that a graph is
two colorable providing that all the
cycles that it has if any are of even
length of course a tree has no cycles so
that makes it 2 colorable for sure